so characters okay
I gave this a c plus
there's a particular set of characters
and I thought they got them
fundamentally skewed
hello everybody and welcome to another
episode of the after show today we are
going to be breaking down
the season finale and the whole season
of The Last of Us just that little show
that just a few people are talking about
it's created so much
conversation Gamers have been talking
about some big burning questions that
the uh the show left behind in season
one they've been talking about it for 10
years but for us newcomers we're just
learning about this big conundrum uh
that we're gonna get into but before I
go any further just a warning this is a
spoiler-filled episode so if you have
not seen the last of us or the season
finale go check that one out and then
come back and visit okay so today I'm
really excited about our guests first we
have Skyping in Matt Cabral he is a
writer he is a consultant
for game Goat how are you
I'm very good how are you today Nikki
very excited to get into this and I'll
explain why in a couple of seconds but
part of the reason I'm so excited is
because
edcilla our beloved edcilla tell me your
title what is your exact title together
all the time producers Rotten Tomatoes
nothing too fancy like what's your exact
time supervising producer oh okay give
yourself more I appreciate that but he's
joining For the First Time The reason
I'm excited is because we all sort of
have different entry points into The
Last of Us Ed you are a gamer or at
least you love this game and how long
have you been has this been a part of
your life well 10 years ever since it
came out 2013 I think the original game
came out right Matt I think it was 2013
or so correct I was 23 at the time uh
and it was just one of the best
experience I ever had it's one of my
favorite IPS of any genre because it had
that much of an impact on me not I think
both for the Video Game World and the
narrative World kind of merged those two
worlds for the for the first time
um and so it's been a long time and so
we're gonna get into like that question
about like video game adaptations and
your your take on it but Matt what is
your entry point into this whole world
of The Last of Us
yes similar to Ed um you know the year
the game came out 2013
um prior to that I was just a huge fan
of sort of single player story driven
video games and this was sort of the the
Pinnacle of those you know just
fantastic uh characters stories just a
great again story driven single player
game and got one of my favorites
and my entry point is yesterday
I am not a gamer
I I read other than Super Mario
I think five Donkey Kong when I was a
kid that that's pretty much it and I'll
watch my nephew play games but you know
he's intact can you name the console
this is how we'll know hell no okay
there we go
the what
uh anyway so I binged the entire Series
yesterday I've been busy with Oscar
stuff and thank you it was the only time
that I had to do this so I think we're
gonna all come at it from very different
perspectives or at least the two of you
and I are gonna have different
perspectives so let's dive in yeah we're
gonna start with the season finale
everybody's talking about and the big
question you've known for 10 years I've
only had a night to process was Joel
wrong swear to me that everything you
said about the fireflies is true
I swear
okay and I'm gonna start with you Matt
for me yeah I'm gonna sound like a
monster I guess here but that never even
really occurred to me I I I was right
with Joel you know
um the the easy answer I guess is that
you know I'm the father of a teenage
daughter so you know I I somewhat put
myself in in his shoes and I and I think
if I was put in that position well yeah
you know of course I would do whatever I
had excuse me whatever I had to to
protect my daughter
um but you know I think there's more to
it than that as well I just think the
way
um you know Marlene has a history with
Joel she has a history with Ellie but
despite that there's there's no
conversation between them there's no sit
down between the three you know
discussing whether or not this is what
they all want to do if they're all on
the same page with it it could have been
handled in a more adult or mature way
among these three I think
I mean I hear you about being a dad and
you know Pedro Pascal is the ultimate
zaddy at this point like once you've one
once you've drafted with somebody you
got to protect them right
exactly
right okay my take
huh
look Joel is my guy I've Loved Joel as a
character for 10 years wow he's
incredible like he's a protector you
know he knows what he needs to do and
especially for like a like a male like
me who's not built like Joel clearly uh
I respect that very much and especially
because I love Ellie
and so
Joel is wrong though like I what he did
was wrong I think
I mean I think objectively I think it
was wrong but I get it I 100 get it I
don't blame Joel one bit because
especially as someone it doesn't matter
if it's a daughter whoever my mom
anybody care about I don't think I could
make that I don't think I could let that
happen either I mean come on right if
that's it's it's it's the world or
it's the world or your own and in a
world that Joel lives in where
everyone's just an ass you know it's
terrible
and especially what Joel's been through
I'd be like
no yeah I'm gonna choose me you know I'm
not going to live forever but I found
this like light in my life and I want to
have that why wouldn't I I think he was
wrong in the sense that look he had this
opportunity to save humanity and he
chose to save one person for his own
feeling it was actually selfish it was
selfish
but let's be frank
it's the freaking person that was wrong
she
she's wrong it's not a
they're not Joel was wrong Marlene is
the one great point that did not give
Ellie the option yeah she did not and
she was like we're gonna give you some
tests or whatever maybe
just let her know Ellie is that person
that Joel knew would say I'm doing this
and would probably do everything she
could to block him out and lock him out
of a room so that she could go through
with it let me ask you a question okay
if Marlene gave Ellie that that to to
get her point across to get her
perspective on it do you think if Joel's
in the room hearing that do you think
that Joel would still let that happen I
think if she had said like they have a
very very
they have a gorgeous relationship and
initially no he would probably say to
her no no no no you're not doing this
but the way she can win him over she
might have been able to convince him
look go find your you'll find your bliss
again like you'll find somebody like I
know you're going to lose essentially
two daughters
but at the end of the day that was her
choice to make
and I understand as it like when it
first happened the thing that the thing
that made me laugh was he's been taken
down people all season right like he's
been taking there's been some situations
where I'm like there's no way these two
would have gotten out of this like they
just messed up too many narrow things
but when the doctor who's like 90 pulled
that little tiny knife on him that was
an inch long and he was like I'm gonna
shoot like and that made me laugh I'm
like I think you could have found like a
more peaceful alternative in that
situation but that's the moment he went
on the offensive rather than the
defensive well to be fair he had a whole
Army that could be busting behind him
anymore true so but the Marlene moment I
was like oh he lost me like he lost
me because he did when he shot him down
he shot her when he shot Marlene but
then I but I also get it because she
would have come after her what do you
think I don't know that was the moment
but then I came around again and I
understood it well Matt what do you
think this is the beauty of this whole
thing too is that it's completely
ambiguous right it's just there's no
right answer but Matt do you have a
right answer I'm not saying Joel would
have liked it right if Ellie knew if
Ellie knew it was coming I think she
probably would have you know agreed to
make the sacrifice I agree and I think
maybe she could have brought Joel on
board you know with that decision
Marlene shouldn't have told him she
should have just done it and then told
him she should have just lied to him
yeah she really wanted to happen because
she knew what Joel has been capable of
exactly you know Joel's not a nice guy
he's not uh it's hard yeah it's a hard
it's a hard thing you said something
interesting though Matt you brought up
the fact that uh Ellie probably would
have chosen to have killed her uh been
killed for the sake of humanity I agree
with that and she even says it it's part
of the trailer for The episode like no
half measures she looks dead in Joel's
eyes right right before yeah during the
giraffe uh scene where she's like no
half measures we're gonna go all the way
with this and I think in that mode she
knew she knew that entire beginning of
the episode that's why she was acting
that way so sort of away from me not why
she was acting in my opinion man I don't
know but in my opinion that's what she
was she was going through her head about
like she it's coming to an end this
could end badly for her yeah
very withdrawn and then that that you
know portion of the uh the show and the
game you have to move on a little bit
but here's the question too
he was wrong he lied to her face yeah
and that's the moment where you're like
this is bad because they have that trust
that has been built up right and when he
looks at her and says you know does the
lie and you her face you know he's lying
by his face and she knows he's lying she
doesn't know what about
but that's also that's also that was the
ultimate betrayal absolutely well it's
confliction to the the the ultimate
level again with any narrative I've ever
seen like after that game I was like I
don't know how to feel about this I am
glad that they're both alive that's what
I did know is that maybe at the end of
the day which now after that whole like
it's a 15-hour game you know or 10 to 15
depending on what what you're playing
it's a long game yeah spend a lot of
time with them this Show's only nine you
know less than nine hours
um you really feel it you know and you
want them to be together at the end of
the game I think most of us wouldn't not
want them to be together I want them to
be together forever absolutely that too
is amazing well let's talk about a
little bit more about the episode the
way it opened with Ellie's birth
Ashley Johnson who played Ellie in the
original game playing Ellie's mother she
I mean the casting all season long solid
chefs freaking kiss solid which we will
get to but gosh darn it and I love what
I love is when they choose actors that
we don't all know yeah yeah and so you
can really get involved in them
sometimes a movie star will take me out
of it to a certain degree when it's just
all movie stars but just they found the
right people but but Matt what was your
uh your take on that opening birth scene
yeah first of all how awesome is it that
you've got the you know the actress who
originally played Ellie now essentially
she's Ellie's mom and this is all tied
into uh again where Ellie's immunity
stemmed from just after seeing that
scene I was pretty blown away and I also
kind of felt felt bad for Troy Baker
because I feel like you know he he had a
cameo the week before and I feel like
his Cameo is fine but I feel like he
kind of Drew the Short Straw there in
terms of getting a really sort of meaty
sort of meaningful uh cameo in the show
but yes I I loved it now did they I mean
because she lies and she says about the
umbilical cord like I cut it before I
was infected right was that consistent
to the game no so as Matt said that
entire scene is not in the game
oh I missed a completely a new addition
to to the lore I guess that uh yeah yeah
so it was really fun that's what's
that's what's really cool we actually
this is the first time that anybody has
learned the uh Ellie about Ellie's how
Ellie's immunity could have could have
come across right because the first time
flashbacks yeah you didn't see that okay
which is really cool I don't even see
her mother in the games I mean she's
referenced uh occasionally but you never
see her so yeah I thought it was great
that they they added that scene and it
wasn't just a a sort of cheap fun Cameo
but like I said it you know really added
something to the story and really tied
into the story of of Ellie's immunity
our doctor
he thinks that the cordyceps and Nelly
has grown with her since birth why is
she in surgery it produces a kind of
chemical messenger it makes normal
cordyceps think that she's cordyceps
it's why she's immune on a on another
level I kind of liked the idea of not
explaining it at all because it doesn't
really matter at the end of the day you
know because it's not what the story is
really about I like the mystery of it of
whether or not you know how that
actually happened but yeah at the same
time I think it works for the show
beautifully especially for those who are
seeing this for the first time to kind
of understand where that's coming from
and also just the the theme of like a
motherhood right like a mother
protecting their child in that way
um past her death I thought that was
really beautiful but yeah that that
whole thing is new to everybody and this
is the one thing about the show that
does really well we'll talk about it
later but the additions I thought were
incredible the things that were not in
the game right I thought they made a
really good choice across the board of
like the things that were done we'll get
we'll get into that later but well best
casting of a baby ever that baby was the
cutest thing I my biological clock
started ticking I was like oh my gosh
could it be mine that was a gorgeous
baby can we just applaud like how babies
in movies and TV have gotten better over
the years because before
like kind of things and you're like
that's really weird yeah have a friend
that every time like a child actor or a
baby you know sometimes there's a child
actor in the scene where they're not
really in the scene they're a part of a
scene and they're ripping off and you
can tap like she sees it and she's like
it pisses me off that stupid child actor
ruined it for me
but yeah in this case so let's talk
about how they did on the app on the
adaptation
um of this episode like the giraffe
scene I mean that was just gorgeous that
was so good that's a real giraffe by the
way yeah no I mean you could tell
I don't know maybe
partially is that CGI would they get a
real giraffe I know they did was that
cool wow yeah and they even extended a
bit in the in the series you know at
least feeding the giraffes and such
which uh doesn't happen in the game so
yeah it's a really I think it's for fans
of the game I think that was sort of a a
fan favorite scene or moment that people
wanted to see and I think they did a
great job of that yeah
sorry for the lighter a lighter moment
to it you know a show that is so you
know regularly so Bleak and heavy so it
was kind of cool at the same time they
added some stuff that I thought was uh
you know additive that you know they had
the the scene with uh Joel and Ellie
just kind of having a little bit of
quiet time bonding uh Joel revealed that
he had um previously attempted to take
his life after Father's Day that was a
big addition yeah when we played the
game that was that was not something
that Joel ever announced to win the game
interesting because that also stood out
to me yeah as certain things just stood
out in terms of it didn't feel like it
flowed with the subtlety of this I agree
with that I wasn't thrilled about that
moment I get why they did it you know I
mean this is the final sort of alone
time they get before his big decision
they have to sort of hit home like this
is how much you mean to me yes because
they never really say it me too though I
I agree and in the game is the same
reason go again but that's the
difference though is that 15 hours of
gameplay you really get to feel that in
nine hours it's harder to do yeah so I
get it so I I I'm on both sides of it
you know there's again it's an
adaptation so I can see why they make
certain choices to really favor the TV
crowd versus those who played the game
and that's one of those things again I
don't really think it's necessary but I
get it so you know yeah yeah no it's
funny that you're pointing these things
out because it's all the little things
that may be very smothered me very small
but or not bothered me but they just
didn't seem consistent maybe when they
talk about a show being uneven those are
the things that made it a little uneven
for me because what they do so well
and we'll we'll get into the whole
series but what I love about what they
do in this series is you know there's
been other post-apocalyptic shows or
Series where they go oh remember when we
used to eat strawberries remember when
we used to do this and you don't feel
the meaning of it this show immerses you
so much into that world that when they
do eat a strawberry when they do like
the scene where Ellie's like reading the
diary and she's like girls used to worry
about what skirt they wore to school
like those sort of things hit home
because you're so immersed you feel like
you're in that world that you forget
what your own life is like and you go oh
yeah that would be
that was like they they don't need to
hit you over the head with stuff it's
just it's just it's just they bring you
in in such a way they don't need to
overdo it but so let's go
um let's go back and let's rewind and
let's just dive into the entire season
one overall are you guys ready I'm
excited so much to say the yeah so much
to say okay so overall
um this this has been a critical darling
the Tomato Meter score on this is 94 for
season one the audience score is 89 and
did it go down sorry did it go down did
you say 89 that's 96 96 certified fish
yeah the audience score no no no no
tomatoes oh I wrote 94. maybe 96 96.
okay let me start that again okay so 96.
there you go two more percent let's give
them two more they deserve it okay the
critical consensus is retaining the most
addictive aspects of its beloved Source
material while digging deeper into the
story The Last of Us is binge-worthy TV
that ranks amongst the all-time greatest
video adaptations do you concur with
that Matt and Ed start with you Matt
yeah I mean I think before that you need
to say
um you know it was not the show that
broke the video game Paris there's a lot
of you know when the when after the
premiere aired the first couple of
episodes there was a lot of Articles out
there a lot of discourse saying you know
Yep this is the one this is the one that
finally broke the video game curse so as
a long time gamer and a long time TV guy
I need to say that that was not the case
there you know there were other uh
shows out there and granted they were a
bit more Fringe less mainstream a lot of
animated stuff there was the Castlevania
show
um League of Legends Arcane uh cyberpunk
again animated stuff uh not as
mainstream not as accessible but they I
think you know got there first as far as
breaking that curse
um
and also other live-action stuff you
know uh there was The Witcher first
season The Witcher I thought was very
good technically based on the books not
the games but but close enough
um and even Halo I know I know Halo uh
divided a lot of audiences look at look
at Ed's face no comment
it wasn't awesome it wasn't fantastic
but I but I enjoyed it
um I thought it was a good video game
adaptation
um but yes all that said I would say the
last of us is yeah well you know Far and
Away probably the best I I won't give it
the crown of breaking the video game
Paris but I will say it is it is
currently the best video game adaptation
all right add season one adaptation
report card time go
all right so I made a report card and
Matt did too I want to get mine you did
too okay yeah yeah I've got my grades
here I'm out of this one okay yeah
by the way by no means do I think that
uh Matt and I are speaking for the you
know the the gamer crowd as as a whole
especially those who've played the game
but we are we are definitely coming from
that mentality I think so just to put
that in perspective but you know yes so
what we're gonna do is break down
um the show to its Story characters
Easter Egg Slash callbacks additions
cuts and then the faithfulness overall
faithfulness and I gave each one um you
know on a ranking from F to a uh what it
what it what I thought it deserves so
and Matt you can go after me after each
uh category just to get her thank you so
okay so from a story perspective overall
I think season one I would say A Plus
I I mean you know it it's it it not only
basically told the story uh of the game
as it was it made incredible and this is
another thing later additions to the
story that that I think furthered my
involvement into into what I already
thought was you know something I've been
attached to for 10 years and I didn't
think could get any better and they made
additions that I thought made that even
better so story a plus Matt I'll Echo
those same sentiments I mean a plus for
sure
um I was pretty Blown Away by the story
um I I spoke to you uh earlier even
before taping this Ed and I said how you
know jealous I am of the folks who have
not played the game uh like yourself
Nikki who just got to go into this fresh
and just you know get to be surprised by
all those uh twists and be shocked and
heartbroken by all the deaths and all
that stuff I I knew it was coming after
playing the game you know multiple times
but I still thought they did a great job
uh so let's move on to characters okay
this is going to be where people may
start to hate me and why okay
would I would get I you know that's the
word out now in the modern day which I
hope not hopefully please try not to
hate me too much just my opinion it's
impossible to hate Ed oh thank you
impossible well we'll see this might be
the the time get controversial to it
like your first episode
so characters okay oh I gave this a c
plus I'll get into I'll get into my
reasons later okay okay but overall I
think most of the characters are good
there's a particular set of characters
that I thought was particularly vital to
really get especially for coming from
someone who loves these characters very
very much and I thought they got them
fundamentally skewed so we're gonna wait
on them for some of the issues that we
have later okay just to give people
enough time too okay are you shocked I'm
shocked as an audience member who
doesn't know anything about the games
because I thought it was brilliant but
go for it yeah I'm pretty shocked um I
probably uh just turns off his camera
leaves Gary I'd probably give the
characters an a
um you know it and it was hard too
because I you know having played the
games a few times the original the
sequel the the uh expansion the DLC
expansion
um I I really grew to to appreciate
these characters love these characters
so I was a little hesitant you know when
I heard about the casting and and you
know finding out that you know these new
these new folks as talented as they are
were going to be you know playing my
beloved Jill and Ellie Tommy was good I
thought and uh oh Tommy was so great the
creepy cannibal uh cult leader guy David
he was a son of a wow
the actor is great I don't recognize him
he's so good I forget his name but he's
amazing he's awesome wrote it down I'll
find it later yeah we'll talk more about
that but he was wonderful yeah Pedro and
belly uh Bella sorry playing Ellie and
Joel but let's call her balance
Billy Pedro and Bella uh took me an
episode or two to warm up too but yeah I
got there okay bless your heart man
really are you gonna hate on this oh
you'll see hold on all right we'll get
there okay uh then next Easter eggs and
callbacks and when I say this I mean
just sort of the
um extenuous details from the game you
know anything that would that hearkened
back to the game so like the use of like
ladders I thought was sorely missing but
at the same time we got that great
ladder scene in the last episode I'm
kidding of course but just the overall
sort of like how the games itself and
like the mechanics and getting into the
show I give it a good B plus I thought
they did a great job one thing that I
was sorely missing that is like a like a
you know a huge part of the game are is
shootouts I felt like they could have
had a little bit more shootouts and and
uh Close Quarters combat a little bit
that would have been nice in terms of an
action standpoint not a not a hit on on
the show at all again I get it I think
they Cho the things they chose made a
lot of sense but you know when you're
spending
I don't know 12 hours just going crazy
on people John wicking it on people it's
like I kind of wanted that like nice
like nice shootout scene but I wouldn't
get that but no there wasn't a ton of
that right no no and that's fine again I
get it but it would have been nice as a
gamer till like I'd seen a little bit
more in that
um and a lot of these sort of uh side
stories that you get by picking up like
um uh what do you call it those uh you
fall upon a lot of just documents and
memos in the game that still tell Side
Stories like specifically for those in
the game like no uh oh ish ish that was
a wonderful story about these um this
person who had to deal with the kids
inside that um
that makeshift sort of school that we
saw underneath with the Henry and Sam
it's a beautiful story in the game um
that that unfortunately was like you
know ended in tragedy right there's no
time but they had a great you know call
back to that which I thought was great
but overall I thought I was pretty happy
I would uh probably go with an a for the
uh
um Easter eggs callbacks
um nods to the to the game there was a
lot if I had one thing that was you know
Ed mentioned that there weren't enough
shootouts I would have liked to have
seen even as just sort of a a fun sort
of joke or not some more Scavenging or
rummaging for supplies there's so much
of that too you're right you know you
enter a room in the game and you go
through every
blocker and file cabinet and then you
make yourself like uh a bandage or a
Molotov cocktail right
those uh yeah I forgot about that making
having to make your weapons along the
way yeah and we never got a scene like
that would have been nice because you
make like a smoke bomb that's like
really cool uh what do they call it
uh it's also a bomb but it has like a
bunch of nails and and scissors in it
and stuff you throw it at people just
get demolished it was just cool if they
could make the series where you could
choose to go in that a different path
like the choose your own choose your
adventure you could choose to like
rummage through something but I kept
thinking how hungry they must have been
through the whole thing like and how
like the best before date on those cans
oh like the ravioli I was like oh
sweetie I don't know I mean everyone was
fairly fit in this world but for a good
reason the fact that it's been 20 years
Pedro Pascal had some you know half down
yeah where's he getting these steaks or
something you know like burgers I don't
know he's getting something
all right uh okay moving on to some of
the additions okay this is where I gave
it a straight A I mean particularly
we're gonna talk about episode three
because that's an incredible episode but
talking about in addition it's probably
the best Edition I've ever seen in an
adaptation particularly for the video
game I mean talk about completely
turning it on its head of what you saw
in the game and then adding to this
story that they were telling I thought
it was just incredible and there's more
scenes like that through I don't I won't
waste time here but a for that yeah
really impressed by the the Edition
Kathleen I I thought was a really fun
character you know I already loved the
actress I love Melanie lynskey
um so I was happy to see her in the show
I was disappointed to see her meet such
a uh ugly demise so quickly yeah I I
could bloater and baby were phenomenal
having I text Ed this morning he was
like he knows my taste this isn't
normally the kind of series that I would
like choose to watch I really wasn't
sure and he's like I have no idea where
you're going with this I actually really
liked it and I was just like blow the
rules man like I want more well now I'm
getting you in my last Christmas present
baby Yoda get me uploaded rules
and actually fight the bloater do you
think you would actually play the game
Nikki I would play the game I think I'd
be into we might have to do like a
twitch stream of you playing because I
did watch a side by side on YouTube of
like the real real verses and I was like
they did a good job right I mean overall
good job like when people talk about the
casting I'm like how could you not think
that these two were perfect I mean just
even facial features like Bella Ramsay's
facial features are so similar to the to
the game character and and you're like
no you're like no is she not okay so
let's get into that okay okay well let's
finish it off let's finish this report
card off well I'll do two cuts so Cuts
as in things they took out again I give
it a minus I think they did a great job
cutting things out there's some things
where I was like I wish I saw that but
uh overall I think they did a great job
and then overall faithfulness yeah
elegant a minus see that c plus brought
it down but overall I I mean it's a
great it's a great show and I think they
did it great again it is probably the
best video game adaptation
um ever made yes I agree with that
should we go into characters now is that
our segue do you all want to yeah
because I really want to know now you're
taking so should we go like let's well
let's we'll get some issues I guess
let's start with yeah well let's start
with the two leads do you have an issue
is that your report card okay go this is
where we put spoiler warnings this is
where the trigger warning
first of all I want to preface this look
I'm coming from again I'm coming from
the perspective of the gamer Who Loved
this game okay if you didn't play the
game and you love these characters as
they were written in the show that's
perfectly fine I have no issues with
that complete makes complete sense to me
okay so don't don't listen to me okay
but as someone who I mean I love
these characters I love Ellie in
particular she's one of my favorite
characters forget female like she's a
great character in all of one of my
favorite characters in all of movies and
and and and all of it I dressed up as
her at Comic-Con actually in 2013.
that's how much I loved her I was Eddie
we're gonna insert a photo here
let's ask the producer so when going to
the show I was like whatever happens the
most important thing to me is that they
get Joel and Ellie's relationship
correct
that was the one thing that was
important to me and for the first few
episodes I was like I don't know it's
not all there but I think I'll give it a
shot to the end and see what what they
do
unfortunately
um it's there's a point where I go okay
this is not working because they made a
fundamental change to Ellie and Matt you
may you may disagree with me but that's
fine but for me
um Ellie is just not the same Ellie as
she is in the game for for a key reason
she is much less vulnerable in this in
in the show in the sense that wait she's
more vulnerable in the game she's more
she shows more vulnerable vulnerability
in the game in oh because she's a much
more sweet girl at times where she needs
to be but she's still also the warrior
that's what's great about Ellie in the
game is that she embodies these two
these two sides of herself so well she
knows exactly when to be
um respectful and kind and open and
trying to get to Joel when she needs to
and then when she needs to Xena Warrior
Princess it out she knows how to do it
too she doesn't take from anybody okay
in the show that vulnerability I don't
know about you but for me I was like I
don't see that side of that that
vulnerable side's gone especially in the
first scene that she shows up in when
she's shacked up I mean and this is a
this is a purposeful move from the
writers because it's for in the first
scene you know she goes one two three
four
you yeah funny that's fine funny but
it's clear that that that mode of
operation in her head that is what is
going to take her throughout the rest of
the show and it does like if you've
noticed like in a lot of scenes she's
she's spunky she's sassy I get it you
know but
I'm sorry but it's also kind of
every every once in a while it comes off
as really I'm sorry and it's not
likable you know there's Parts where I'm
like that's not you're not a likable
person Ellie there's Parts where if I
was Joel I'd be like bye I'm gonna look
I'm gonna Hawkeye and I'm gonna look
this way and maybe I'll click a clicker
kind of comes out of nowhere fascinating
Ed let me just say I am the first person
that when they I have told you this
before I don't like
superhero movies female Heroes all this
stuff where women feel like they have to
act like men men like tough like oh I'm
tough it was tough as you I can fight
like you again and what I loved about
the first I'm going to bring up one the
first Wonder Woman was that Wonder Woman
had that vulnerable side and that that
softness yeah but then she was fierce
and I love that dichotomy between the
two one room is actually a great
parallel to it but characterizing having
known nothing about the game
I freaking love this actress and I feel
like everything that came out of her
mouth even like the dinner scene when
she's sitting there eating the dinner
and they're like she's like this is the
first meal I've ever had
in my life is amazing like and
just the way she just like they they
sort of they overlap their lines
sometimes and stuff comes out of her it
feels organic too it doesn't feel like
an actress playing tough right it feels
like this organically is who this
actress is in this particular role I
don't feel like she's putting something
on to I'm gonna be a tough chick in a
movie right
what
what's wrong with you what about her
manners that I liked but I understand
what you're saying that if that wasn't
how the character was sort of written in
the game yeah that it is a departure
from the character not the way she
played it exactly no I'm not hitting him
Bella whatsoever I don't Bella is is
fine I think she does a good job I think
she can be a little bit one note every
once in a while but she's fine I ended
up liking her a lot
um as an actress it's not her basically
what I'm saying is that it is it's a
different character it's a different but
I don't I don't personally like that's
all I'm saying it's not just not wrong
it's not wrong by any by any means but
it's just different I loved my Ellie and
this is not the Ellie
Matt yeah
settle the debate here come on Matt dig
into me
you know I I would agree with that I I
did notice those changes in Ellie um I
didn't feel quite quite as strongly as
as about them as far as you know not not
liking her as much
um yeah but definitely more vulnerable
in the game
um I I think probably a big part of it
and this doesn't necessarily make it
right is you know I think the the
creators are are prepping her for season
two
um because there's a there's a lot of
stuff that we're not going to spoil uh
today I guess but there's you know Ellie
needs to be really tough uh you know
what you've seen in season one you're
not prepared season two is very Bleak
and uh yeah she needs she needs to be
tough for season two and and I want to
say again it doesn't necessarily justify
it but I think maybe you know when they
were writing the first game and they
were writing Ellie's character they
probably didn't know at that point where
were they where they were going to go
with the sequel game
now of course you know in retrospect
they know exactly where they're going
with the second season of the show and
they know they need this sort of
hardened tougher maybe not as likable
Ellie but why couldn't they have have
her evolve as starting out a certain way
and then you see the evolution that
might that could have been interesting
sure no I mean I would probably uh want
it that way too but I will say Matt
you're 100 right like you're 100 right
that's the reason no ad where she goes
oh I know and we're not going to spoil
it we're not going to spoil it spoil it
not for our viewers
but you're 100 right and one of the
reasons for that is that you know
for those who know part two of the game
was largely taken over by Neil druckman
who is is a CO is a writer and director
on the show it's basically his baby uh
but he was part of part one as well he's
creative director and writer then part
two he's largely taken over as creative
director and he they definitely write
uh This Ellie like this is the Ellie
that I see when I watch the show is that
alien part two and that and I 100 agree
with you it's like well
that makes again that makes sense it's
his show it's whatever right like that
makes sense to me but at the same time
again not to get it to it well I guess
we'll talk about season two now but uh
that part two is very controversial that
game was received critically well but
for the fans of the game oh boy it's con
that was that game's more Infamous I
would say for having split the community
on certain decisions that were made uh
both narratives make both narratively
and and character yes character-wise so
we won't get we cannot go I know we
cannot we cannot delve into there maybe
off offline off cam but he's that's
correct is that I see that led now in
this Ellie but in which case I can
that's fine maybe that's what but I
don't know too much I thought it was a
bit of an over correction
I hear you I I miss the games Ellie as
well okay okay Max so kick us off um
with Joel as a character and Pedro
Pascal can we say anything about this
man can we can we
I I thought he did a great job you're
talking the actor not the character I'm
talking both like overall how he did as
as Joel I was a little maybe a little
hesitant when I heard he'd been cast
because I thought it was like okay he's
really popular now Mandalorian so
they're just throwing the hot new actor
into the into this big uh you know
Prestige television series but no uh I
was pretty much sold right in the first
episode I thought uh he was great and I
thought uh Bella was great and the
chemistry between them was you know
aside from the things that that Ed
mentioned which are absolutely spot on
with Ellie being you know portrayed a
little bit differently a little bit more
hard-edged uh no I thought they were
great
I agree I oh I love Pedro who doesn't
love Pedro right now I love you daddy
he's daddy if if Captain America is has
America's ass he's America's daddy like
for real what is his saying like about
him having to travel with like the
chosen one and protect the chosen one
like he's just like that's such a that's
his now like that's so true don't even
think about that he should have had her
in a bucket like in the thing that he
showed it was in like there's a dragon
girl
um no I he he does it I had the same
thing about Matt I wasn't sure when I
first saw him you know play as Joel but
he not he just knocks it out of the park
yeah Pedro is turning out to be probably
one of the greater actors of our of Our
Generation he can just kind of play it
all he has always reminded me of Burt
Reynolds of Our Generation oh that's a
good one he looks like him I told him
the first time I met him I'm like you
need to play like a in a biopic play
like the life of Burt Reynolds that's a
good one he is a really and what was the
movie why am I blanking when he cracks
the whip what was the movie where he oh
oh uh Kingsman Kings two yeah when I saw
the kingsman I was like who is this dude
like this dude's awesome that's where I
also kind of met him first yeah and then
um massive Talent unbearable weight of
massive yeah he was so good he's
incredible he's so good and he has so
much range and when I'm asleep I are
like awake at night at 3am because you
know how your Instagram shows you what
you look at the most it populates
my Instagram is full of Pedro Pascal
dancing
so when I have insomnia I don't watch
Pedro dance for hours on this dominating
Tick Tock right now he's absolutely
dominating the social space everything
he's on top of the world right now do
you ever feel like you know like when
you discover people from early on and
they're sort of your baby like Austin
Butler I know for a long time that's my
baby and like when people start to like
them I'm like stop it yeah he's mine
when I find like a a gem of a restaurant
in L.A I'm like everyone asks me like
what's good to you I'm like I never tell
them that restaurant Pedro Pascal has
been Hidden Gem that's mine that became
like where all the cool kids go and I'm
pissed off now I want him to be mine
yeah okay well let's let's dive into
um some of our favorite moments our
episodes
um from from season one so Matt for do
you have a favorite episode and or a
favorite moment we'll just use you as a
jumping off point
yeah that's that's tough to pick a
favorite um I I really enjoy well let me
start with the favorite moment
um scene between the the older couple or
older couple played by Elaine miles and
Graham green as a great scene in the cat
in the in the in the cabin oh my God
um and they were just so great like I
want to see if their spin-off show like
they were oh my God they were not
intimidated at all no
best line of the whole season I wrote it
who's the little psycho what did I just
say Joe come on there's like a thousand
who's this little cycle when the guy
walks in yeah
she says uh yeah we get those in the
summer
what are fireflies were amazing I
thought they were so good that I thought
we were going to see more of them the
greatness about that scene is that we've
we don't get that in the game either you
just these two people who are completely
outside what is happening politically in
the in in the world loved it yes you're
that's a great moment Matt yeah I almost
forgot about that moment that's true
because it's such another perspective uh
outside of their own and a place so the
dynamic they're so so funny it's just a
great moment of levity
um you don't get that in the game at all
no I'm pretty much focused on Joel and
Ellie you don't see a lot of that
outside stuff
um and speaking to that same point of
things that you don't you know that kind
of expand beyond the Joel and Ellie
story I enjoyed the stuff uh early in
the season they kind of set a precedent
the first couple of episodes had these
sort of flashbacks where they showed um
yes the very first episode I think it
took place like in maybe the 60s it was
a talk show something like that yeah but
they were talking about the
possibilities
yeah and then in the second episode
there was the doctor from Jakarta and
she she had seen like the first patient
just I I love stuff like that I love the
sort of sort of World building stuff and
to sort of get out of the um you know
the sphere of just sort of the main
characters and see sort of what was
going on beforehand so in a way that
that was great but it also it
disappointed me a little bit that they
didn't continue with that stuff I
thought there would have been more of
that yeah um
like I totally 100 agree with you one of
the best additions again I gave it a
plus is those those scenes those intro
scenes and I thought they were gonna
keep going with that intro in every
episode with something from before yeah
they stopped that which is you know it's
just yeah it's just a point I wanted
more because they're so good so all
those scenes were not in the game
whatsoever you only the only time you
ever see back in the past is the very
beginning of the game when you play as
Sarah uh Joel's uh daughter
um and that's it that's all you get zero
nothing else well that doctor was great
she had that one line yeah we're not
even a line of words she went bomb um
foreign
[Music]
stories bringing in new characters when
you're so attached to the two main
characters you have a hard time having
them be invested they get you so
invested each episode is could be
defined by the one character's name and
you get so invested in them but that was
true she was fantastic and what I do
like about the series too is it reminds
me I was a losty I was a lost boy you
realize you like lost dude
are you kidding we known each other for
like five years it's the best show of
all time flashbacks yeah that feeling of
they're not these people aren't on the
island sort of like longing for the past
times but the flashbacks into their
world before even Ellie in the final
scene seeing her being born and seeing
the Innocence yeah what happens is like
yeah it's like I love those flashbacks
that are so emotional
[Music]
um but so Matt what was your fate do you
have a favorite episode
uh favorite episode there's probably two
I I did like the um the adaptation of
the the Left Behind uh expansion from
the game uh partly because I wasn't
expecting it I don't know if that was
announced and maybe I was trying maybe I
was trying to avoid spoilers and then
just didn't notice but when that episode
came on that was one of my favorite
parts of the game and uh Nikki I don't
know if you know it was totally optional
it wasn't in the main game it was sort
of a expansion you could play later on
so I'd probably tie that episode with
you know the the horror fan and me would
probably tie that with the incredibly
unsettling creepy cannibal David episode
that was just a horrifying it was like a
horror movie that episode yeah but I did
enjoy it I enjoyed that section of the
game and and I thought the episode was
done really well as well and what was
your favorite scene slash episode well
I'm glad that Matt chose two ones that
are not on mine because they're they're
equally I don't fight you on that at all
but I I obviously I think I gotta bring
up episode three uh with Bill and Frank
uh talk about a show talk about uh an
episode of TV that's just absolutely
outstanding just on every and not again
not only just from a regular viewer but
from the video games uh video Gamer's
point of view too because that entire
story not only didn't happen in the game
it's not it's they changed Bill's fate
because you you only meet Bill in the
game it's a section in the game where
um it's in between I forget which ones
what what places but essentially you do
fall into Bill's town and you have to
get through it you need a car battery or
a car too and Bill helps you and that's
it
um and then how Frank plays into it is
that they're fading that game so much
more it's so much darker essentially
what happens is near the end of that
that whole
um incursion with Bill you fall upon a
house a random house you get it for
safety you find Frank who has now hung
himself because he got bit and this is
the first time that bill sees this body
hanging there and not only that you then
find subsequently a note written by
Frank that basically says I hate your
guts like I I I loved you but at the
same time I I you you kept me
uh controlled in this in this world of
yours where you don't want us to sort of
expand outward you're too afraid of
everything but they were together they
were together they were Partners okay um
and so but they he he their relationship
completely fell apart completely
different in the show that sounds like
could it be farther from the reality to
my life well sure
yeah and maybe that's what was going
through yeah right maybe that was more
real than what happened uh in the TV
show you know but the TV show I mean I I
applaud uh Mazen
um who is one of the one of the writers
and Neil uh for for writing this episode
who took the risk I mean it's a huge
risk you know to completely just
uh build a whole new story on an
existing character where people know it
and make this beautiful love story I
mean it's just a Lo this this love story
is just tragic and made me cry wept I
just absolutely wept at the end are you
kidding me I mean and those two
performances were amazing and again I
just I thought it was such a great
episode to go away from Joel and Ellie
completely without any you know warning
seamless seamless and then also then to
add them at the end of the episode and
it being the impetus for Joel that's not
in the game I thought that was the best
thing is that in the game Joel he
doesn't he doesn't bill is not the
reason he chooses to go with Ali at all
to step up this is the reason he does
because of that amazing note at the end
and I was just like this is when he
pulls up at the uh wow I'm like this is
this is how you like how you completely
type something else together to the next
level and tie things together in an
incredible way we give love Offerman all
the awards right now and Murray I forgot
Murray Bartlett Murray white incredible
yes now that will be the episode if the
Last of Us recognized come award season
I'm calling it now for directing of an
episode that is winning the end 100
nothing is comparing it's done the Emmy
is already over everybody else go home
already it's in September but it's done
it's gonna be hard it's early in the
year but that being said it's a bar
that's going to be very hard to beat my
second favorite or actually a close
maybe even tied was episode six the
Tommy episode The Brother episode in
that Community I absolutely loved what I
loved about that is he sees his brother
and he's like there's a line that he do
know what I did for you to get here and
his brother's like dude I'm chill like
that's the Brilliance and I don't know
what element of the game how that
factored into the game and you can
explain it to me but again on a regular
TV show it would have been like brothers
they hug and then everything's all great
and the relationship between his wife
Maria and Ella when they have that
private scene and she gives her the
thing for her period and the clothes or
whatever it is sorry and then again
another Regular Show would they would
have seen these two women bonding yeah
they're bonding because those are two
females right and the fact that they
kind of went at each other and didn't
get along
and she wasn't like thank you for the
coach she was like the freaking purple
whatever it was eggplant like that again
like just because it's two females we
don't have to you know they don't have
to have that yeah you have to have that
oh
you know Sisterhood relationship right I
found another woman in this room Hey
look
well yeah that was I mean more I will
the one thing that was huge hugely
different in that episode is that uh
Jackson Wyoming right where that that
settlement is that you don't see that
until this is not a spoiler but in part
two there's a part two of the game yeah
they they lift that from part two and
transplanted that to part one completely
in the game you meet Tommy and his um a
small group of survivors at a dam
they're trying to restore electricity to
to Jackson you actually don't see it yet
um
that's where he sees his brother again
so they don't get introduced to the town
at all so that whole part of that
episode specifically was definitely new
was exploring Jackson was a completely
new thing for at least this part of of
the game again we do go there in part
two
um but yeah
but the drama in that episode is very
much
um at least the the essence of the drama
in that episode is from the game where
we you know that there's that amazing
scene uh where Ellie and Joel their
their emotions for each other sort of
collide for the first time yeah again
afterwards she's reading the um the
diary I'm not her you know
Maria told me about Sarah and no
no say another word
another word I'm sorry about your
daughter Joel
but I have less people too
you have no idea what loss is it's that
scene actually is a slightly different
and this is where we'll get to issues
but overall again for TV I think it
makes a lot of sense but it's it that
was one of the most powerful scenes in a
video game ever ever done at the time
like a lot of people look to that scene
in the game as one of the best cutscenes
of all time
um and so I think they did a good job
overall I think that him and his brother
those scenes were good too because like
that's not in that's also not in the
game where uh Joel opens up and cries
um to in front of Tommy right man I'm
pretty yeah that's not in the game and
ask him to take her yeah it's more kind
of brushed over you know he wants
um he wants Tommy to take Ellie on the
rest of the journey but it almost comes
off a little bit more as selfish maybe
self-serving in the game where you know
he kind of feels like he's done you know
he's done his part he's done with the
journey correct yeah no and that's a
great point and that's the that's the
part where I was like I'm not sure if I
love that change but it's not a deal
breaker but in the game Joel's the way
that Joel feels about it goes about his
feelings about leaving Ellie's is
is jump started differently because in
the show I think he's more vulnerable
definitely like he doesn't cry in the
game ever and that's not a bad thing
that in the show he does that's fine I
mean men can be vulnerable that's
totally fine however he he's definitely
yeah overall though when he steps into
the room he's he's more like a dog with
a tail between his legs because he feels
bad and he shows that a little bit but
in the game it's very different because
that scene is triggered where Joel is
upset at Ellie for having because in the
game Ellie runs away after having heard
that he wants to leave her she it's an
extended sequence and she he's initially
very angry at her because he's trying to
protect her and she just runs off not
knowing that he had heard that she had
known that he was going to leave her and
so she he storms into the room very very
angry and he's very defensive you know
he's very high in a lot of ways a little
bit more hostile than he is in the show
so that's a big change in terms of the
what the the structure of that scene
emotionally which again they're both
fine you know I I prefer the game but
anyways matters
I was just going to say the whole thing
where he you know he talks to Tommy and
he you know genuinely believes the best
course of action is having Ellie go with
Tommy because she will he truly believes
he really cares about her at that point
he truly believes she'll be safer and
the whole thing with him having the um
you know he sort of has the anxiety
attacks on the show
um the panic attacks yeah I guess yeah
that's not in the in the games at all
again so I want something that stood out
that wasn't necessary I thought not not
that they shouldn't address it but I
thought when he was standing on the
fence kind of like having a friend and
she's like What's your deal I I that
again was maybe too much Exposition
maybe it could be it could have been a
little more subtle I don't know I know
it's interesting you bring those parts
up that you say like these things aren't
necessary because I I felt that way too
like especially with that I don't know
if I really needed that from Joel like
needing to know that he had anxiety
necessarily uh mostly because I think we
get that already I think it comes
through yeah because what I respect
about Joel is that he has to put up no
matter what is happening he needs to be
the guy he cannot he cannot show that
otherwise they die like that's his
mentality in the game right you know any
small part of vulnerability at least
outside is going to catch them dead you
know in that moment who knows who's
watching them and if he's on a fence and
he's like having that attack you're like
they're dead right
um but again but to to to the writer's
point in this episode would be making
Joel more vulnerable that scene when
they're in closed doors he's he's having
this moment with Tommy the only person
he can have this the cry in front of
right that made a lot of sense to me
yeah that's fine to me you know that
made a whole lot of sense that like
behind closed doors you gotta if you
need a breakdown breakdown you know
that's also strength but I was
disappointed that when he got out of
that room he kind of was still in the
same mode he didn't sort of you know zip
up and go like you know I gotta I gotta
approach Ellie like this and maybe it
was because we never really saw the
anxiety before that moment and then all
of a sudden he's having he just kind of
has it well you would think that after
20 years of the that he's done or
like maybe the first time
yeah it came out of nowhere it came out
of nowhere I think that was my issue
with it but the fact that you sort of
you're mad at Tommy because in a sense
like you know look what we've been
through what they've been through look
what we've done to get him here like as
an audience member Tommy how are you not
and you know he's torn because of the
wife situation yeah everybody knows
somebody who's been in that situation
right like like I really want to go out
with the boys tonight but I was never
gonna let that happen and the wife
I don't think the wife is pregnant in
the game right is that right Ed
um no she's not I don't believe so no
you're right that's a that's a different
change yeah that's an additional
that she's not she's not um she's not
pregnant you're absolutely right yeah
which surprised me that he
I like the scene between them where he
pleads with him but I was surprised that
he agreed to do it like I guess it is
his brother at the end of the day but
I I actually thought Tommy was going to
say no me too I thought it made sense
for him to say no just because one again
you know he's had this contentious
relationship with Joel he doesn't really
want to follow him anymore because Joel
keeps throwing it in his face that like
you know what I did was for us and he
clearly is like is not on that train
yeah you did I didn't ask you yeah I
didn't ask you to do this you did it and
you're putting it on me I don't like
that but also I thought yeah obviously
having a child is a really good reason
um not to so you know ultimately we know
why it's because Joel's gonna uh choose
to anyways but and when he says just
because you I've moved on with my life
just because you haven't you can't you
know drag me down either way I like I
thought just as props to Gabriel Luna by
the way who's he's a great Tommy I
actually think Gabrielle is a better
Tommy than Tommy was in the game oh
really yeah I liked him more in the show
all right well this was a true blast I
had a great time this was so great Matt
you rock
oh thank you so much such a such a
privilege and a pleasure to be on with
you guys really appreciate you having me
so now we're going to turn the cameras
off ERS off and they're going to tell me
what happens in season
I really all right let's do it let's do
it I'm that person I can watch spoilers
and it doesn't ruin it for me let's do
it now and I'll just pray like an
extended beep just throughout like for
five minutes do it okay here we go here
we go thank you everybody for joining
you guys can continue your own
conversation go down a rabbit hole of
spoilers and if you know the games and
you already know where it's going but
thank you so much for joining us here on
the after show oh we gotta push we gotta
push too
to what what what's Matt up to oh yeah
Matt tell us where we can find you
oh okay um you know I I write for in
addition to you guys for Rotten Tomatoes
I'm actually you mentioned spoilers I've
got I've got an article going up uh
probably later today or tomorrow which
actually speculates about what's going
to happen in season two and it does
include those big giant spoilers so
Nikki feel free to check that out
um in addition to that yeah you know I I
cover film TV video games I'm on CNN IGN
um Rotten Tomatoes of course and uh
Common Sense Media a bunch of others
your best bet is to just check out my
Twitter I post all my my content there
but I'm all over Matt yeah and I will
say and I forgot to shout this out at
the beginning I did read a couple of
your RT articles and for people you're
in for a treat please read his articles
and his breakdown this and then
everything else it does there's they're
so like so good digestible easy to read
but thorough and like great perspective
and great it means a lot of things so
everybody please uh check those out Ed
where can we find you well if you're in
the RT office you'll definitely find me
over at the snacking at the the
cafeteria other than that uh you can
find me on my Instagram at let's explore
but also me and my buddy of mine have a
podcast for movies where we review
movies everything everything under the
sun uh it's called Pizza Time nerdcast
check us out on Spotify and uh any other
big podcast space uh apple apple
podcasts stuff like that um if you want
to have a good time we're actually
covering a huge part of Cinema that is
not told largely which is Indian Cinema
we we're doing a lot of that it's
incredible like Indian Cinema is amazing
if anybody hasn't catched not just rrr
but just like any other Indian Cinema
they're doing it better than than us I'm
telling you right now I agree the stuff
that I have seen they have some
incredible ignorant saying that elephant
the Whisperer oh no yeah that's a great
I mean that is so good Matt if you
checked it out it's the short film that
won at the Oscars for best documentary
short it is I in my opinion the best
move movie of the whole year including
the long-form ones it's incredible
now based on that recommendation really
good absolutely again the the Indian
Cinema is incredible you should check it
out but if you want to if you need a
guide we can be that guy for you and any
other sports as well and I'm Nikki Novak
I'm permanently attached to this chair
you can always see me on Rotten Tomatoes
and Fandango and we'll all be probably
chatting for the next two hours as they
tell me everything that happens in the
game but for now we're gonna end this
episode thank you so much for joining us
and we will see you next time on the
after show bye
thank you